اعلنت الصين اقامة علاقات معها
لتنضم الى قائمة دول اعلنت مؤخرا
السياسيين الامريكيين من بينهم
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ورئيسة
مجلس النواب السابقة نانسي
بيلوسي. روسيا تشرع باول خطوة
واقتصاداتهم تنهار ولم يحقق
نتائجهم المرجوة. وكانه قد حان
نتنياهو بتعليق العمل بها.
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن شن
طهران انه لا اساس للاتهامات
الامريكية ولا ادلة عليها مؤكدة
مسبوقة لرئيس التيك توك التنفيذي
في الكونجرس الامريكي. نعم يا
الاسرائيلي من منصبه بعد ان اعلن
رفضه للتعديلات القضائية مطالبا
يا هؤلاء? الاحداث والتطورات.
ناشطون يقتحمون بنك بوكليز
في ضواحي مدينة تولا التي تبعد
مائتي كيلو متر جنوب العاصمة
التكنولوجيا وهنا الخارجية
الصينية تشدد على ان واشنطن لم
ترامب ان التهديد الاكبر ليست
الصين او روسيا ولكن كبار
اصحاب العيون الضيقة لا ينسون
حربهم ضد الامريكان. حتى في مجال
سيعطي دفعة ايجابية للاقتصاد
العالمي وفق قول جورجيفا. لكن
الدولي ان حصة الصين في النمو
الاقتصادي العالمي ستبلغ الثلث
بانها سترد على اي هجوم ستتعرض
له قواعدها في سوريا. قال دونالد
بتمويل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي.
نتنياهو يقيل وزير الدفاع
والمنافسة العادلة والتوقف عن
قمع الشركات الصينية وفق بيان
تقدم اية حتى الان يثبت ان تطبيق
التيك توك يهدد الامن القومي
عن ذات الخطوة بعد وعود صينية.
وهنا ياتي سبب تهافت الدول على
الوزارة الصيني. جاء هذا الرد
الصيني بعد جلسة استجواب غير
الداخلية الاوكرانية تستعد
للانضمام لقوات الجيش على
البريطاني بمدينة مانشستر
الانجليزية احتجاجا على مساهمته
الاستسلام. وها هي تستفز الدب
الروسي مجددا. حيث اعلن خدمة
ون فوتي وان محملة بالمتفجرات
وفق وكالة تاس الروسية. الخلف
وقت الاستسلام. اليس كذلك يا
اصدقاء? لكن يبدو ان كييف ترفض
الطوارئ في مدينة تولا الروسية
عن اصابة شخصين جراء انفجار كبير
ان الدول الاوروبية متعبة من اثر
العقوبات التي فرضتها ضد موسكو.
لايران شمال سوريا. مضيفا انه
مستعد لمزيد من الاجراءات لترد
غارات دقيقة ضد ما قال انها
منشآت تستخدمها جماعات تابعة
الداخلية والامن. هناك اكد
مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني الاسبق
في عام الفين وثلاثة وعشرين. هذا
الانتعاش القوي للاقتصاد الصيني
لتتساقط عديد الدول في الاحضان
الصينية ودون عناء. هنا ساعات
في الجبهة الشرقية ستة الوية تضم
الاف المدنيين التابعين لوزارة
قليلة فصلت قرار هندوراس بقطع
علاقات دبلوماسية مع تايوان. حتى
الحلف الصيني. حيث قالت
كريستالينا جورجيفا مديرة صندوق
الصيني العظيم. قائمة الحلفاء
الصينية اصبحت تعمل المغناطيس.
موسكو. هذا الانفجار جاء بضربة
من مسيرة اوكرانية من طراز تيو
وتريد بدء الرئيس الاوكرانيسك
المفاوضات فمخازنهم تنضب
الامريكي. داعية واشنطن الى
احترام مبادئ اقتصاد السوق
سادة فعلاقة بكين بواشنطن تتجه
نحو المسدود. فماذا بعد هذا كله
الجبهات مطلع الشهر القادم اي ان
اوكرانيا اصبحت تقاتل بجنود
البلدين لا تشكل تهديدا لاية
دولة. ومن استعدادات الحرب
نحو شيء واحد. نعم. انها تلك
الحقيبة. حقيبة بوتين النووية
القوة التي السلام والاستقرار
العالميين مؤكدا ان العلاقات بين
وسيأتي الرد حتما حتى لو لم يكن
بوتين موجودا حينها. وهنا وزير
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
لنشر اسلحة نووية تكتيكية في
تايمز البريطانية ان القوات
الاوكرانية تخسر من مائة الى
مجددا ليقول انه لا شيء غير
اعتيادي هنا. الولايات المتحدة
لتأتي الاجابة من كييب هذه
المرة. فمع ارتفاع وتيرة الحرب
تجاوزوا جميع حدود اللباقة
الدبلوماسية والاخلاقية على حد
الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل بلاروسيا
على عدم نشر اسلحة نووية روسية
اشراف ضابط امن مسلح. يرافق
بوتين في حله وترحاله لا يمكن
وهي احدى اخطر الحقائب في العالم
ان لم تكن الاخطر. تبقى تحت
الخارجية الصيني بان العلاقات
الثنائية بين روسيا والصين هي
مائتي عسكري يوميا خلال المعارك
الدائرة حول مدينة ارتيموفيسك.
النووية الى حرب اوكرانيا
التقليدية. حيث قالت صحيفة صنداي
التكتيكية على اراضي حلفائها.
وتابع اتفقنا على القيام بالامر
سواء. ولا يستبعد تجاوزهم لحدود
اخرى وفق قوله. ليعلنها وزير
مدار اليوم. فيها زر واحد يعرف
باليد الميتة. فاذا احس بوتين
فدعت الى اجتماع طارئ لمجلس
الامن الدولي من اجل بحث خطة
على اراضيها لانها ستواجه المزيد
من العقوبات بحسب فخرج لهم بوتين
رئيس هيئة الاركان العامة. اي ان
بوتين لن يدعى عمله للصدفة
ليست وحيدة. فهناك اثنتان اخريين
واحدة لدى وزير الدفاع واخرى لدى
بتهديد وجودي لروسيا يمكنه فقط
ضغط ذلك الزر ليتم اطلاق الاسلحة
النووية من جميع مستودعات
الاسلحة الروسية. هذه الحقيبة
تفعل ذلك منذ عقود. هي تنشر منذ
زمن طويل اسلحتها النووية
وجيش الاوكران يفقد افراده
تباعا. فكيف يستمرون بالمقاومة
الخارجية الروسي سيرجي لافروف
يؤكد ان ساسة البيت الابيض
بيلاروسيا. بينما حث مسؤول
السياسة الخارجية في الاتحاد
فتحها الا برموز سرية تخضع
للرقابة اربعا وعشرين ساعة على
نووية ليعود البنتاجون مطمئنا
بانه لا وجود لمؤشرات بشأن
بقنابلنا. قبل ذلك كان بوتين قد
اعلن نشر اسلحة نووية تكتيكية في
يا هذا? لتأتي الاجابة بسيل
التقارير العالمية. وجميعها تشير
نفسه. مؤكدا الحصول على موافقة
بلاروسيا. اذا ما الذي تخطط له
للغرب. ليوجه رجل الكرملين الاول
رسالة مباشرة وجهتها هذه المرة
قنابلنا بل تزود اوكرانيا
بالقنابل. وعندها سنمطر سماءكم
المنضب التي لم تستخدمها بعد
وكانه يقول اذا اردتم رؤية
استعداد روسيا لاستخدام اسلحة
نووية. اما الحكومة الاوكرانية
الكريملين بينما قال حلف الناتو
انه متيقظ ويراقب الوضع
والتطورات. اما اوكرانيا فقالت
ان روسيا تحتجز بلاروسيا رهينة
بلاروسيا موضحا اكتمال بناء
منشأة تخزين للاسلحة النووية
فالبيت الابيض والبنتاجون
يعتبرونها مراوغة سياسية من
على اقتصاد العالم وصندوق النقد
الدولي يؤكد وحرب التكنولوجيا
روسيا او الصين مشيرا الى ان
التعاون مع الصين لا يشكل تهديدا
هي بريطانيا قائلا ان لديها
المئات من قنابل اليورانيوم
التكتيكية في روسيا بحلول يوليو
المقبل. هناك جنون الغربيين
بقوله ان الغرب هو الطرف الذي
يبني محورا عسكريا جديدا وليست
الصين. روسيا تبدأ ردها القاسي.
خطط الروس تمضي بنجاح. والتخطيط
الاسرائيلي وترامب اعظم تهديد
ولايات المتحدة ليست روسيا او
ينضمون للجيش الاوكراني. فهل
انتهى العسكريون? الصين تسيطر
تشتعل بين بكين وواشنطن.
والانقسامات تندلع في الكيان
الصين ولدينا مئات من قنابل
اليورانيوم المنضب لم تستخدم
بعد. فهل من هدف محدد يا هذا?
واوكرانيا تعلن بلاروسيا رهينة
ليأتي الدور على الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين. ليعلنها صريحة
الغربي لم يأت بجديد وكذلك
العقوبات الغربية عادت على
اعلنها الكريملين في وجه البيت
الابيض. والزلنسكي يدعو مجلس
وبكين بدلا من تدمير الروسي وفقا
لصحيفة برلين سانتونج الالمانية.
اصحابها بنتائج عكسية ليعترف
الغرب ان عقوباتهم المناهضة
لقد تجاوزتم جميع حدود اللباقة
وتعديتم الخطوط الحمراء هكذا
لروسيا لم تؤتي ثمارها. بل وفتحت
افاقا جديدة للتعاون بين موسكو
الاوكرانية تضرب مجددا في
الاراضي الروسية الاف المدنيين
والعالم يحبس انفاسه بسبب حقيبة
بوتين المرعبة. والطائرات
الامن الدولي لعقد جلسة طارئة.
وبوتين لم نشكل تحالفا عسكريا مع
نووية. فهل تكتفي بذلك ام ان
الحرب النووية قائمة لا محالة